bangladesh faces increasingly extreme
weather
due to climate change and recently a
sudden short heat wave
destroyed more than 68 000 hectares of
rice crop
affecting more than 300 000 farmers
mohammed saidu had expected to earn
enough for him and his family to survive
the year on the rice
he cultivated but now his crop is gone
there was this hot wind that lasted for
several hours at night time
by morning the entire crop in this
wetland area was wiped out
now there is nothing for us to survive
on i can't express it in words
and so far we haven't had any help from
the government despite their promises
officials say farmers have received help
the local agriculture office has
conducted a field survey
and made the list of the affected people
and we started dispersing money to them
through mobile phone apps as aid
provided by the government
but many farmers said that the lists
were made and handed out by local
politicians and they never received any
help
thousands of farmers across bangladesh
like here in natsukana districts
have lost their rice crop due to sudden
heat stress
in recent months many are now worried
how to pay back their loans
and to make their ends meet
sixty-year-old farmer riyazuddin says
he hasn't seen anything like this in his
lifetime
i had to borrow money from the agribank
to grow the rice i was very hopeful i'd
be able to make some money and pay back
the loan but suddenly it's all gone
i'm not sure how i'm going to manage
things now
scientists say a heat wave reaching as
high as 36 degrees celsius
and high speed dry winds were
responsible for the damage
they say hardier varieties of rice are
being developed to withstand the changes
in weather conditions
climate change the heat stress is due to
climate change
it's something very new to us although
we have observed this before
on a very minimal scale but the scale of
damage this year
is huge we think the damage could become
worse
in the future bangladesh is the world's
third biggest rice producer
scientists warn the recent rise in
temperatures linked to global warming
is making rice crops particularly
vulnerable and could threaten food
security in many countries
tanvi choudhary al-jazeera naturakuna
bangladesh